The Joe Rogan Experience when I was
working on the Ironman project it's a
fireman project it was the Iron Man
project what is that so we're trying to
build the suit really we've been working
on it for a long time I didn't know I
was not gonna be getting a project it
was called carnivore at first and a few
other names but in the beginning it was
only a small handful of us working what
are they using to make the body suit out
of it's it's changed so much right now
that it's all kinds of materials I mean
titanium carbon fiber all the top stuff
and is it supposed to be able to fly
it's going to do a lot of stuff does it
have an exoskeleton so it's Stronger
Yeah and it's much stronger you can
carry you know a thousand pounds yeah
stuff that stuff's wild we're getting
there but if you think about that kind
of a suit that exoskeleton
how are you going to move that
exoskeleton those people so if you had a
if you had a squad let's just say you
had 12 dudes in those exoskeletons What
airplane are you going to use what
Humvees what vehicles how are you going
to get these guys around what boats it
changes everything right they're a
thousand pounds yeah Jesus Christ so you
can only get like a couple of those on a
plane
yeah maybe four I don't know but that's
but that's one of the issues that we're
running into is the fact that if we
start going this direction we start
going to exoskeletons we have to change
everything else that makes sense and
when we were doing it it was like the
long poles intent for the you know and I
was on these think tanks and I was
always like to innovator see I was a
weird seal you already know that I guess
well I guess we get to that part how was
the tacky part so I was very technical
and I was working a lot of the uh
National Laboratories so all the places
that we built the you know Manhattan
Project we still have all those
facilities all around and so we still
use them if we work with them and we try
to push the envelope for military and
civilian use so there's a lot of things
that I was part you know innovator
inventor of stuff that's gone to the
civilian world and uh
the Iron Man project was a really cool
and what are they powering it with
that's the problem was that I'm pulling
a tent I kept talking to him and I was
working with all the National Labs
specific Northwest and all those guys
and uh nuclear battery was pretty much
the only way you can go
so it would be that it'd be a little
battery about that big
we've already had a cell phone in my
pocket but we've had those little
nuclear battery since the 50s so it's no
big deal but those nuclear batteries
like how dangerous it for a human being
to be around it
how dangerous it is to be in a military
that's true too we jump on an airplane
to 30 000 feet but if you I would feel
like if you wore that thing around you
got horrible bone cancer because of it
yeah you got lead Shield thinking about
other shielding yeah but the thing is
there's so much power and there's so
much everything else we were using the
uh Hypersonic flywheels and using all
this other stuff we're trying to do
energy storage in all kinds of different
ways is there a way to Shield it so that
a person can be in direct contact and
not receive be carried around in a
suitcase really yeah yeah Jesus Christ
yeah there's a couple of them isn't it
funny like that's the one of the things
that we're scared of the most I have to
be careful some of the stuff I say I'm
like I'm constantly going are you saying
stuff that you know you could not edit
it out you're saying no there's classic
Iron Man is not class anymore they've
talked about I think it's in Popular
Mechanics now so but I think some of the
people that worked on it are still
classified and some of the stuff they're
doing now is probably classified so this
is all that all data is that a situation
where as new technology comes out then
they revise it yeah until they so
they're always working on it but it's
not always working on it so it's it's
it's usable some of the pieces like
right now I mean my back is just toast
like all the Seal Team guys because we
carry those large rucksacks and
constantly out there jump you know free
fall and jump in Parachute and all that
stuff our backs are just toast so what
we're trying to do is trying to get it
just first is like load carrying and so
they made it try and that was one of my
biggest pushes in the beginning of Iron
Man was I said we need to build
everything
as non-energy consumption everything has
to be uh you know pneumatic or Springs
or somehow using our body to propel
everything because if this whole thing
shuts down the battery turns off you
have to still be able to move a little
bit at least to be able to get off it
from here to cover over there so you
don't get you still have to be able to
move it so it's a thousand pounds how do
you move that thing right which has no
power how would you is it possible that
was like where the direction they went
in was the direction I didn't want to go
was you can't now you can't it's you're
gonna be stuck so the power goes off
you're Frozen there you're just yeah
you're almost it's big as if you're in
the middle of some sort of an operation
and there was a solar flare yeah and the
solar flare nukes all the electricity or
something yeah you're screwed yeah yeah
[ __ ]
I mean how the [ __ ] could you move it
how could you if you're stuck in a
thousand pound robots
you're done that's what it looks like
right now yeah so these things are still
tethered a lot of those so okay so that
is um that's the exoskeleton goes down
his legs and that's those things on his
legs yeah but that's that's even a way
no that's CGI I don't know if that's a
real one and so but it's pretty much
like that and it attaches here around
your waist and it kind of works off your
hips
and then uh so this is one right here
and so you see he's got this so he's got
his down the sides yeah that's that's a
that's a regular one with no power so
that's an unpowered one and how does
that use those little things on his legs
and up around his waist it might be
slightly powered but those things on his
legs I know I have up there will be like
a piston really and then that will be as
you're moving your leg
it all works off your own kinetics you
know it's all off and it helps you move
yeah and it can carry large weights so
you can go faster you can carry a lot
more weight why don't I have one of
those in my life I need one of those
paralyzed people they run up hills they
work with paralyzed people they have
people that were paralyzed and they can
attach all this stuff to them and they
can walk around and do it so this one is
powered and see what he's got a thing on
his heels like that yeah that was a big
thing because when you step your feet
pivot somewhat so you have to watch
these things where you put it and how it
goes like there's so much to this thing
you would not believe it it's wild
there's a lot of technology in that
right there alone and so ultimately they
want it where it covers your body like
an Iron Man whatever is that just that's
the ultimate would be when you start
putting armor and everything on it
that's a little bit more yeah
and so that's all lightweight style hobo
cops yeah that's wild that's why it's a
direction we're going in but you can see
even that guy right there he's gonna
have a hard time getting out of vehicles
and doing a lot of stuff so as you keep
adding stuff on there right we get
bigger bigger look how big that guy is
he'd have a real tough time getting
inside of any Vehicles yeah and he
definitely is not driving anywhere so
that's so that's what the pros and cons
it's like yeah we have all this we have
that but now we have to redo the
vehicles we got to do this there's a lot
too how in oh that might be if you look
up carnivore the first one how far do
you think they are from developing
autonomous robots that replace people
anyway in these situations I think so
with weapons because the stuff I was
working on
10 and 15 20 years ago and how fast
we're advancing back then so I would I
would walk into a place in a via VIA
chip manufacturer for us to do our
sneaky peaky bugs and stuff and I would
show them I say hey this is what we're
working with right now and if we would
give them three million bucks make it
half that size and it's all weird you
have to say here's three million half
the size really and then within six
months I'd give it to us here half the
size and so when we're doing it and for
my budget I think I had like 60 million
dollars so and it's we it's huge budgets
when you get to top levels of the seals
and we really push it and we're
constantly pushing these envelopes of
technology and so you can kind of see
like even when I was there I know the
sizes and I know like you can have a
chip and you have a chip inside of a
chip and a chip and a chip and a chip so
you have you can go all these layers all
the stuff you start digging
and then every time you have the chip
there's a lot of subroutine sub programs
and everything else you can put into
them there's it's just mind-blowing how
advanced we are so if you when you say
do we have autonomous right now we have
airplanes Vehicles we have all of it
already
we're fully capable right now to go
almost autonomous and it's crazy